Speaker 1: Let's go to Aaron from Los Angeles.
Aaron, welcome to the show.
Speaker 5: I did it.
I just wanted to ask a quick question regarding
I guess, I don't know, intellectual copyright
is the term, but there's been like I've been
reading a lot of articles regarding, I guess
like Bill Gates.
And just to be clear, I am not an anti-vaxxer,
okay?
I mean, like I'm triple VAX boosted and everything.
So before I go into this, I just want to say
that I understand that Bill Gates is a source
of a controversy when it becomes, I guess,
like intellectual property and copyright,
like he has been getting involved in a scandal
regarding vaccines not being distributed to
the global south as quickly as they should
be.
And a lot of people are identifying this as
a major reason the COVID 19 pandemic isn't
slowing down.
I was wondering, what could our Congress do
to perhaps reform our intellectual copyright
laws to prevent, I guess, big pharmaceutical
companies from preventing, you know, necessary
access to vaccines?
Speaker 1: Well, with it with vaccines specifically,
the desire has been for the vaccines to to
essentially not be protected by copyright
or intellectual property, patent protections,
and just to be basically allowed to be open
sourced and produced anywhere.
And there was a brief period where Moderna
said, we still have our patent, but we're
not necessarily going to enforce it.
And know I don't know ultimately what happened
with that.
There's a number of different issues going
on with vaccine distribution, but I just I'm
not exactly sure.
With vaccines specifically, it's one set of
problems.
Bigger picture, there is all sorts of other
intellectual property issues that that exist
and would be dealt with in different ways.
So I'm just I'm just not sure how to address
the question.
Speaker 5: Okay.
Yeah.
It's just I know that Bill Gates has been
tied up with intellectual property rights
even since, like his foundation of Microsoft
in the 1990s.
I mean, as a matter of fact, before he was
getting into philanthropy, a lot of the controversies
that he had regarding Microsoft's monopoly
on the software industry were really one of
the things that he was best known for.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there was the big issue about
the bundling of Internet Explorer with windows
in which he gave, you know, hours and hours
of pretty, pretty notable depositions.
And yeah, you're absolutely right.
But to be perfectly frank, I don't know that
Bill Gates is the biggest player right now
in what's going on with vaccines.
Speaker 5: Okay.
I understand.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know that.
It's just like in regards to his philanthropy,
I understand that he does have a lot of influence
with it.
I just think that, like, maybe the extent
could be overstated as a result of, like,
you know, the various conspiracy theories
that are around him right now.
But I guess that is just something I would
look into.
It's just I honestly just think that if we
don't slow down the effects of the COVID 19
pandemic in the global south, we're going
to continue to see these variants.
And I don't really I don't know if it's going
to lead to another shutdown, but I do think
it's definitely going to lead to the spread
of the infection.
Speaker 1: Yep.
And we're seeing cases go up now and hopefully
it won't become a major spike, but a point.
Well said and well-taken.
I appreciate the call very much.
Glad we could speak to a few people today.
Thanks to our guest bailing on us, we'll still
take the broader calls for our Friday show.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.